the the big thing fans of course is fan
art and sarah paska i know you have had
that accolade of people sending you fan
art i mean yeah so i've got one piece
and i think fan art is a strong word
um yes okay
so
it's actually it's worth saying that
it's all of you
it is this is the the fan art of sarah
pascal
now the reason i think fan art is a very
loose term is i was given this at a gig
in lieu of payment
don't brag about my career
but that's because the guy who ran the
gig had spent too much at the bar
to pay me so he painted that yes
after being at the bar
what are those bits i just think they're
just free
biscuits
donuts or something
you can send
pictures of people who tattooed your
face on their bikes oh no i'm not there
yet
have you have you guys yeah one day
i get them in my twitter feed all the
times guys who have
whole calves the calves or a picture of
jewels on their chest or
nick fury
you know people love the event and now
tom middleton you have found offered
such specific fan art that's a lot yeah
and does it all come from this one scene
it was it the first thor movie with the
spear right right yeah yes um there's
there's a scene in a first thor film
where my i'm trying to attack
thor chris hemsworth as thor with a
spear
and i jump in the air and he dodges out
the way and i
bring the spear down and it wedges
itself into the floor and then i use the
use it to spin myself around and kick
him in the chest
which has been interpreted by fans
as
a demonstration of my hidden talent at
pole dance pole dancer
yeah no actually there's so much of this
but this is just one example of loki
really going for it on the pole
is that japanese and that's what you
wear in the movie yeah
have you not seen it yeah that's loki's
very quickly it is uh oscar's weekend
this weekend and uh ian would you mind
telling us the story about when you were
nominated for
uh
gandalf
and you had the the beads yeah
well they weren't beads
uh
in in
new zealand where we filmed lord of the
rings uh
[Applause]
you you you if you're lucky when you
leave you're given a piece of green
stone carved and you wear it often
enough and your chances are you'll get
back to new zealand that's the idea
and it'll bring you a bit of luck so uh
when those films were nominated for
something like 20 oscars
on that night everybody from new zealand
was wearing the green stone that pounami
echo uh and when we're on the red carpet
going into the ceremony i met maggie
smith
what do you mean what are you here for i
said well
i said well lord of the rings oh yeah
she said what's that round your neck oh
so it's my punami
i own your poonami what's that if i said
well
if i wear it it'll it'll bring me luck
and uh oh very nice
and we went our separate ways and you
know it lasts for three and a half or
four hours you know don't you oh yeah oh
god you just sit there and sit there and
at the end of course everyone else wins
the oscar apart from you
i'm a bit dejected you're coming out
looking forward to a drink and you bump
into maggie smith and she points at you
and it didn't work didn't it
[Applause]
you played carol hatcher
and now so how much preparation goes
into
we'll obviously put a nose on it i did
have a note
but what else goes on
preparing for carol thatcher
i should make up some for them
i watched i'm a celebrity get me out of
here
um but now but when you're playing at
something like a detective do you do
like for broadchurch did you do
preparation
no
sorry um david did and i could ask him
questions
it seems silly doubling up
to defend my actions um i don't think my
character spoke in the same sort of um
rhythms as detectives so i thought it'd
be better if i didn't have that
influence
you're a good answer do you dance a lot
though yes thank you for saving me i do
in that um
well uh nick frost is the lead guy and
uh he uh as a child oh and i'm his
sister that's it i'm his sister
um
and as children uh he was salsa champion
endless cups and awards and things and
we used to go off and do competitions
and i was his dance partner and then
something happened and his life changed
and salsa wasn't for him after that
moment
and then cut to
nick frost's present day
or whatever his character is called and
um
bruce he's called bruce
like how many people are applauding you
remembering the names of people in your
own films
you know this feeling you filmed
something
nelson mandela
and i know we know you're not into big
you're not a big preparation but you
must have had some dancers had to i was
forced to um because i had to dance on
screen
so i had to practice do you look good
though well there is as you know they
have people who actually can dance yeah
who uh because i can only spin three
times before i vomit so
we do we have a picture of you in
rehearsals where it doesn't look like
it's going that
that's the well thing i've ever seen
i also love that you're wearing like a
full sweatsuit and heels what was it
what did you perform you performed at a
seafood festival i mean
which what show you want to know
about
in luxury you know venues wherever they
feel that they can build the stage and
make money is where you're going so
there was a crab fest
and it was like we're gonna book some
talent
comedian talent
and i was like all right well you know
i'm
available and uh i don't know if you
guys have ever tried to tell a joke
while people cracking crabs
it's not the best environment
i mean
literally the frustration that comes
from not being able to open a crab
you're not funny at the same time it's
stuff that you hear i remember hearing a
woman
an older lady who was like she was
cracking crabs
because this is how you crack cracks
looking at me and she's like cracking
the crap i tell a joke and the joke
doesn't work and i remember this lady
just going oh no
[Laughter]
i don't think
i would much rather be booed
from her voice and this oh no she said
baby it was like oh no baby
i made a mistake
with my choice of life like
i'm not doing it wrong i mean you know
look the the the hardship that i went
through has helped help build me into
the person i am today where i i can take
so much but i've been through it all i
was i was hit in the face with a buffalo
wing
i performed that don't perform around
food
now there's no food alive
uh it was it was a it was actually a
male strip club that they shut down for
comedy for the first half so it was like
a bunch of it was ladies in there and
you know it was just supposed to be us
performing for these women that were
riled up first thing i got on stage when
they introduced me and this lady was
like pull it out i said hey
hey
that's not me i'm not here for that
i'm here to entertain he's a joke
i know who's got kids i start
trying to merge into kid material and
there's one dude from the back i just
remember this dude from the back he was
like that's enough and he just
threw a buffalo wing at me
they landed hit me put me in the cheek a
little bit of sauce gala
right here buffalo sauce is hot sausage
i assumed that it was a woman with a
deep voice so i was like who threw it
who threw it
because at the end of the day i'm a man
my man first don't disrespect me
he stood up and he was like i did it and
i
i contemplated just taking my clothes
off
[Applause]
[Music]